hey guys i'm back with another quick tip
uh this one is how to use the windows 7
calculator in windows vista and i'll
even show you a little bit about it um
so here it is this is the calculator
itself first of all how do you get it
well open your internet browser and
google windows 7 calculator
and the first link will be life
lifehacker.com
click on that and you will see a bunch
of windows 7 software available for
windows vista and
one of those will be the windows 7
calculator
so
give it a second to load
all right yeah it's done so
here's the website once it loads it'll
say get the windows 7 calculator in
vista and it'll say windows vista only
i would not try it with xp i haven't uh
haven't attempted that yet i have an xp
desktop downstairs i might just try that
for you guys
um so this is a windows 7 utility
and
all the comments down here it says it is
good
so i downloaded it and
here it is
show you guys
um it works just like any other
calculator uh it you use your number pad
i'm using a number pad right now
uh you can clear your memory it doesn't
have memory in
here i'll pull up the vista calculator
next to it for comparison
so with this one yes you can use the
number pad
this one you can use the number pad
but it doesn't have memory in this one
so if you go to view you have standard
mode and scientific mode
this is scientific mode this is
standard mode for this one you have
standard you have scientific mode
you have programmer mode which is all
i'm binding crap
and you have statistics mode
i'm using it in standard mode i usually
use in scientific mode actually because
i use trigonometry i'm in school right
now
um
that's it's not a huge difference um
it's just shortcuts this one you can
copy and paste this one you can copy
paste and copy certain values and paste
certain values you have history you have
the date of calculation
templates even
separators and then about the calculator
which i'm sure is going to pull up a web
page
this one is just about calculator in
windows vista
so
all right it's it's a minor improvement
but i like the look so i decided to keep
it i put it in my rock which i showed
you a tutorial of before
it opens up over here eggs out
that is windows 7 calculator for windows
vista i encourage you to download it
it's pretty cool and when you
when you do download it you're still
when you search it you have to search
calc
because that's what it comes up as it's
under files not programs
elk and when you click on calc that's
when it comes up it won't if you
actually search calculator
you will only find oh well actually
we'll find it but if you just hit enter
it'll bring up the actual program that
comes with vista
so i saved it to here and renamed it
calculator by going to icon settings
ending calculator
so thanks for watching
hope it was useful peace
you